>> Gillian: GREAT TO SEE
YOU.
>> Tucker: GREAT TO SEE YOU.
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES
REPRESENTS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE PRIDE OF
VALLEY.
HE IS RANKING MEMBER OF THE
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: I DON'T WANT TO
PUT NEW AN AWKWARD SITUATION
BUT YOU SERVE ON THIS
COMMITTEE WITH ADAM SCHIFF.
AND AND SO, AGAIN, IF THIS
IS AWKWARD FOR YOU, I HOPE
YOU WILL JUST SAY SO.
>> I'M USED TO BEING ON YOUR
SHOW.
IT'S ALWAYS AWKWARD WITH
YOU.
>> Tucker: GOOD.
LET ME MAKE IT WORSE.
ADAM SCHIFF HAS SAID A
COUPLE OF THINGS IN THE LAST
24 HOURS THAT GIVE, I THINK,
SOCIALER PEOPLE PAUSE AND
RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT HIS
MENTAL FITNESS.
HE SUGGESTS THAT THE
PRESIDENT WAS, FOR EXAMPLE,
DOCTORING THIS TRANSCRIPT
AND THEN SUBSEQUENTLY
SUGGESTED THAT HE WAS
SPEAKING IN SOME SORT OF
SECRET CODE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> WELL, LIKE MANY THINGS
THAT ADAM SCHIFF AND THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN SAYING
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS.
IT'S BEEN NEARLY THREE YEARS
OF THIS RUSSIA HOAX.
NOW IT'S TRANSFORMED INTO
THE UKRAINIAN HOAX, THEY SAY
A LOT OF THINGS THAT ALWAYS
HAVE ONE THING IN COMMON.
THEY END UP BEING FALSE.
AND THEY ALWAYS -- THEY ARE
VERY CLEVER BECAUSE THEY USE
THE THINGS -- YOU CAN SEE
THE DOORS RIGHT THERE,
RIGHT?
IT SAYS RESTRICTED.
SO THEY WILL COME OUT OF
THOSE DOORS AND THEY WILL
SAY WELL, WE HAVE SEEN SOME
REALLY SECRET STUFF.
WE CAN'T TELL YOU ABOUT IT,
BUT JUST TRUST US.
THIS IS REALLY GOING TO BE
THE TIME THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CATCH PRESIDENT TRUMP WITH
HIS HANDS IN THE COOKIE JAR.
>> Tucker: THAT'S LYING,
ISN'T IT?
>> WELL, ONE PERSON'S LIE IS
ANOTHER MAN'S, YOU KNOW,
JUST TRYING TO GET TO THE
TRUTH IS WHAT THEY WOULD
ALWAYS SAY.
>> Tucker: WE'RE GOING TO
SEE MORE OF IT TOMORROW.
TOMORROW WE HAVE THE
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE, THE ACTING
DIRECTOR COMING IN TO
TESTIFY 9:00 A.M.
EVERYBODY'S GOING TO BE
WATCHING.
THERE IS GOING TO BE
HUNDREDS OF MEDIA PEOPLE
THERE EVERY STATION IS GOING
TO BE COVERING IT, LIVE --
LOOK, THIS IS NOT WHAT THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
SHOULD BE DOING.
IF WE WANT TO TAKE A WHISTLE
WHISTLEBLOWER SERIOUSLY, WE
SHOULD BE DOING IT BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS SO THAT WE
ACTUALLY CAN TALK CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION TO TRY TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT
THERE'S ACTUAL REAL -- IF
THERE IS REALLY SOMETHING TO
THIS COMPLAINT OR NOT.
>> Tucker: I MEAN, HAVE YOU
SPOKEN -- I MEAN, YOU HAVE
BEEN IN THE HOUSE FOR A
WHILE.
YOU WERE COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN.
YOU KNOW EVERYBODY.
ARE DEMOCRATS FULLY ON
BOARD, I MEAN, OFF THE
RECORD ARE THEY SAYING TO
YOU, BOY, WE ARE GOING TO
IMPEACH THIS GUY AND GET A
CONVICTION IN THE SENATE?
DO THEY BELIEVE THIS IS
GOING TO WORK?
>> THAT'S A VERY GOOD
QUESTION.
THE WAY I WOULD SAY IT IS
ABOUT LIKE THIS.
YOU HAVE 30 OR 40 OR SO,
MAYBE A FEW MORE THAT HAVE
BEEN AROUND A WHILE THAT
KNOW WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS
WRONG.
BUT THEY ARE BEING
CHALLENGED BY THE LEFT.
NOW, WHAT YOU ALSO HAVE
THOUGH IS YOU HAVE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE LIED SO MUCH, THE
OLD SAYING IF YOU TELL A LIE
ENOUGH EVENTUALLY IT BECOMES
THE TRUTH.
YOU HAVE SO MANY THAT HAVE
DONE THAT IT'S LIKE EVERY
DAY THEY ARE POURING
GASOLINE ON THEMSELVES.
THEY ARE POURING GASOLINE ON
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY CONTINUE TO LIGHT THESE
FIRES OUT THERE.
WHY?
ONE FOR DONORS.
THEY ARE IGNITING THEIR BASE
TO HAVE DONORS GIVE THEM
MONEY.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> THAT'S HOW THEY HAVE
GOTTEN THEMSELVES INTO THIS
IMPEACHMENT TRAP WHICH IS
TOTALLY IRRESPONSIBLE.
>> Tucker: THEY REALLY DON'T
LIKE THAT WHEN YOU TAKE
POWER AWAY FROM THEM I HAVE